donald trump is preparing to be
criminally
indicted according to maggie haberman of
the new york times
during and after joe biden's summit with
russian president vladimir putin last
week
the republican right did exactly what we
predicted that they were going to do
they said joe biden is going to fail and
he was failing and he did fail
without ever actually explaining how or
why
biden failed they said joe biden has
obvious dimension we're going to get
back to that a little bit later they
said biden's not going to be able to
even speak coherently when he meets with
putin
they said trump would have done better
an obviously laughable claim
but what appears to be going on behind
the scenes according to a new report
from the new york times maggie haberman
says the true realization that trump had
as a result of that putin biden summit
was that joe biden is really the
president right now period there's no
reinstatement coming there's no nothing
trump is now reportedly preparing with
lawyers and aides for a
legal uh for a criminal indictment that
they believe may well be coming check
out this appearance by maggie haberman
from the new york times on cnn
but also i think that it is he is
missing a level of protection
that he felt like he had when he was in
the white house some kind of
if not actual full immunity some level
of a belief that people were not going
to charge a sitting president
i think that he is talking about keeping
his political options alive because he
sees it in part as a shield against
what could be coming that's interesting
do you have
have you heard or what have you heard
about how he is specifically preparing
for this because that presents it in a
new light to me at least that what he's
doing now
is all in or at least partially in
run-up to things that he fears may
happen
look what he's doing in terms of
preparing for a possible indictment is
he is holding a lot of meetings at trump
tower there was a picture the other day
of him emerging from trump tower which i
was surprised it took that long for
somebody to see he was there
he's been there for many weeks going
back and forth between his club at
bedminster new jersey
and trump tower uh he is preparing to
describe this as a quote-unquote
political witch-hunt i think you've
heard that before and i think you will
hear
a lot of that if the prosecution moves
forward as the prosecutors have given
every signal that they're going to it is
going to be a very
familiar playbook but again i just don't
think that you can disentangle these two
things
he's taking meetings in trump tower on
the possible indictment he's meeting
with
lawyers politically he's meeting with
advisors he's meeting with his sons who
you know were running the company while
he was the president uh he is meeting
with his own attorneys
he is there this is a a not the only
focus of attention but it is a focus of
attention
now as maggie haberman points out if the
indictment comes down
the reaction will be predictable it will
be this is another witch hunt
uh they failed on russia russia russia
and they failed on my perfect ukraine
phone call and now they're coming at me
again
the reality is that these are totally
unrelated causes
they are disparate investigations
they're kept being carried out
in siloed ways by completely different
investigative entities
and the reality is trump just did a lot
of stuff
that is potentially criminal trump and
republicans want to frame this as
there are so many investigations against
trump because of the political witch
hunt and the biased nature of everything
that's been taking place
that's wrong the reality is that there
are so many investigations against trump
because in so many areas of his life
personal
campaign business presidential
administration
there are so many areas of his life that
are just riddled with potential
wrongdoing and criminality and it's
going to take years to unwind it all
also remember some of this is taking
longer because trump successfully
obstructed it
while he was president preventing the uh
tax records from being provided to the
manhattan district attorney
um preventing on the rudy giuliani side
trump loyalists at the justice
department prevented the raid on rudy
giuliani's house and
and um office from being carried out
before so a lot of this stuff is delayed
and it's going to take a while because
trump successfully delayed it
now as i've said before if this
indictment comes down
the stakes in my mind are not does trump
go to prison
i just see no chance of that people get
mad when i say it
if i'm wrong and trump does prison time
i will eat my microphone
for me the stakes are whether the
indictments torpedo trump's shot
at being king maker in 2022 and possibly
it running again
in 2024 i think those are really the
stakes here
in a republican party that still mostly
likes trump
mostly supports trump publicly could the
indictments get
so in the way that it leads to trump
being unable to run in 2024 because he
has to beat off all of these
legal cases now hilariously we talk
about
you know under trump the u.s looked a
lot like other countries
there are places like for example my
birth country of argentina
where you can be under investigation and
indictment
and successfully run for high-level
public office
former president christina kirchner was
charged in 2018 with bribery
and still ran and was voted vice
president
in 2019. this is classic latin american
politics while under indictment you run
and you win
could it happen in the u.s sure you know
after trump it would be silly to say
x could never happen because we had a
lot of x could never happen moments
and we were wrong in the united states
but we will take it step by step and day
by day
and the latest news according to the new
york times maggie haberman is donald
trump is huddled up with his legal team
and preparing for what they expect to be
a criminal indictment coming down
against the former president of the
united states if you think things have
been nuts the last week or two
just wait until you see what happens if
and when donald trump is criminally
indicted
follow me on twitter at deepakman let me
know what you expect from trump if
indeed that that day comes
if your job requires you to know what
people are talking about online or
you're just curious what's being
discussed online check out
thought leaders which has an awesome
data platform
that scrapes through youtube podcasts
newsletters every day and analyzes what
is in the content
and then they turn that data into
customizable graphs whether that's a
brand a person a topic anything else you
want to explore
companies can see where their
competitors have been mentioned
marketers can see what trends are on the
rise before planning strategy
or content creators like me can see what
topics and themes are being featured
on other shows for example you can see
here i can track
what podcasts are discussing the midterm
elections
or i can see how many youtube channels
are talking about
rudy giuliani or i can even see what
shows have mentioned
me by searching my own name and you can
use this
for free that's free forever
sign up today create your own instant
thought leaders trends report now
the link is down below